I seek refuge in God from Satan, the accursed.
In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Glory be to
Him [
music] as He
sends down
the angels. Indeed, I do not
fear Him. He
created the heavens [
music] created [music] and
the Qur'an.
Therein is a reminder for you,
and therein is beauty in [
music]
[laughter]
[music]
and bear your burdens.
Except
your Lord, and
good and the rest [
music] is
upon God. So choose, and He is the One who
sends down
[music] for
you a drink, a tree that
grows for you
[music]
by it.
And in that is a
sign. My people remember. And He subjected for
you the night and the
[music] day by His command. Indeed, there is no sign in
you. And what is
different for you on earth
[music]
they remember. And He subjected it, and it is
natural, for you to eat from it and to be
worthy. It comes out free
[music] you
wear and you take it out and cast it into the
earth and purify it. And
I
see and
rivers.
And your question is
concerned and on. And
who
[laughter] his star. So is He who
creates you one who does not create? Then will you not remember?
[music] Do
not
fear. Indeed, God is Merciful.